I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance and what this worst
Thanksgiving week since 2001 might we
have to give thanks for one thing the
25th amendment section for history pays
little attention to this but the first
time an American president died in
office William Henry Harrison just 31
days after his inauguration in 1841
nobody was sure what was supposed to
happen next incredibly the Constitution
was not terribly specific did the Vice
President become Acting President did
his title remain vice-president but he
got executive powers the vice president
John Tyler decided to have a judge
administer the presidential oath and he
spent the rest of his time in the White
House refusing to answer to anything
except President Tyler but even as seven
more presidents died in office the
process was still unofficial worship
twice in the twentieth century
presidents became incapacitated while in
office Woodrow Wilson not only suffered
a stroke seventeen months before the end
of his term but as we are only now truly
learning the stroke affected his ability
to fully understand that he had had a
stroke
President Wilson fought or fired anybody
who suggested he should give up the
presidency permanently or temporarily
besides which there were no
constitutional means for Wilson to give
up the presidency temporarily and the
Constitution still had no official
succession process not for a resignation
and certainly not for a forced removal
because the president could no longer
discharge the powers and duties of his
office and then on September 24th 1955
while playing golf President Dwight
Eisenhower had a heart attack the stock
market panicked it lost 14 billion
dollars in one day eisenhower was
hospitalized for seven weeks and still
there was no specific provision for the
vice-president Richard Nixon to even
briefly assume any executive powers
finally the assassination of President
Kennedy in 1963 brought this matter to a
head not only did the succession need to
be spelled out in a constitutional
amendment but so did temporary transfer
of power and a new idea that if the vice
presidency
became vacant the president should be
able to nominate a new vice president
and it also became clear that death or
resignation or impeachment could undo an
election if say Eisenhower a Republican
had died or resigned and Nixon a
Republican had succeeded him and then he
had died or resigned or been impeached
and removed the constitutional
succession meant the Speaker of the
House would then become president the
Speaker of the House for the last six
years of the Eisenhower term was Sam
Rayburn
a Democrat control of the presidency
would have changed parties without an
election so in 1965 the 25th amendments
of the Constitution was proposed and two
years later it was enacted section one
spelled out the succession to the vacant
presidency section two allowed the
president to nominate a new vice
president which would promptly happen
twice in the next seven years section
three permitted the president to
temporarily transfer power to the vice
president which promptly happened for
seven hours and 54 minutes while Ronald
Reagan underwent surgery in 1981 and
then there is section four written
nearly 52 years ago more with Woodrow
Wilson in mind and yet it might as well
have been named for Donald John Trump
probably easier if I just read this
verbatim section four whenever the vice
president and a majority of either of
the principal officers of the executive
departments or if such other body as
Congress may by law provide transmit to
the president pro tempore of the Senate
and the Speaker of the House of
Representatives their written
declaration that the president is unable
to discharge the powers and duties of
his office
the vice president shall immediately
assume the powers and duties of the
office as Acting President there's more
but I hope you didn't miss the key point
there no hearings no doctors no
conferences no impeachments the Vice
President and merely most of the cabinet
write to the speaker Paul Ryan and to
the Senate President Pro temporary orrin
hatch and they say the president's
unable to do the job and the Vice
President becomes acting president no
hearings no doctors no conferences no
impeachment just by Felicia
of course the suddenly suspended
president can try to regain power to
zooom the section they're after when the
president transmits to the president pro
tempore of the Senate and the Speaker of
the House of Representatives his written
declaration that no inability exists he
shall resume the powers and duties of
his office round one
they say he's unfit round two he says
he's fine he resumes office not so fast
there's a round three he shall resume
the powers and duties of his office
unless the vice president and a majority
and either the principal officers of the
executive department or of such other
body as Congress may by law provide
transmit within four days to the
president pro tempore of the Senate and
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives their written
declaration that the president is unable
to discharge the powers and duties of
his office yes invest in popcorn futures
if the vice president and his crew still
say the president is unfit the president
is not restored to power but wait
there's even more there's a round for
thereupon Congress shall decide the
issue assembling within 48 hours for
that purpose if not in session
if the Congress within 21 days after
receipt of the latter written
declaration or if Congress is not in
session within 21 days after Congress is
required to assemble determines by
two-thirds vote of both houses that the
president is unable to discharge the
powers and duties of his office the Vice
President shall continue to discharge
the same as acting president otherwise
the president shall resume the powers
and duties of his office
instant impeachment for days for the
vice president and the cabinet to state
again that the president is unable to
discharge the powers and duties
triggering a vote by the house in the
Senate within about three weeks and a
two-thirds vote results in the president
remaining in office with the title but
without the power so it's a crazy man
Clause right in the case of trumpet
presumes he behaves as president as he
is behaving as president-elect which is
a good presumption because as president
elect he is behaving as he did as a
candidate for example 24 of his first 40
tweets after the election consisted of
the following six complaints about the
New York Times four complaints about the
cast of Hamilton one deleted one
complaint about Saturday Night Live one
complaint about how
Fair protesters are one complaint about
a news story three boasts about who
called to congratulate him on his
election to claims that he could have
won by a larger margin two lies about
keeping a Ford plant from moving to
Mexico that was never moving to Mexico
two rationalizations about the 25
million he had to pay to avoid a trial
for fraud and two promos for television
appearances one deleted for my money
he's nuts couldn't pass a sanity test
open-book but of course section for the
25th amendment here does not say nuts or
impaired or erratic or unbalanced or
unhealthy or bipolar or narcissist or
sociopath or psychopath it only says
that the president is unable to
discharge the powers and duties of his
office the Vice President shall
immediately assume the powers and duties
of the office is Acting President
Oh kind of vague huh if he was fine
physically even passable psychologically
the Vice President could still
clothesline Trump because he was just to
pick a few inappropriate behaviors at
random of course bringing his daughter
to the meetings with the Prime Minister
of Japan or interrupting state business
to meet with his Indian partners about
Trump Tower Mumbai or pocketing profits
by gently suggesting to foreign
diplomats that the president would
really like it if they all stayed in his
hotel in Washington section four of the
25th amendment to our Constitution
provides the means if they have the
ethics the patriotism and the stones to
use it provides the means to vice
president-elect pence and Trump's
cabinet to remove him from office
basically as soon as the inauguration is
over but of course not only doesn't
section 4 say anything about doctors or
health or psychosis it also doesn't even
say anything about corruption or ethics
or disinterest
it doesn't say anything at all about why
the president might be unable to
discharge the powers and duties of his
office it just talks about letters and
declarations in 21 days and a 2/3 vote a
Republican vice president and a
Republican cabinet and a Republican
Speaker of the House and a Republican
president pro tempore of the Senate and
a Republican House Majority and his
Republican Senate majority can just do
it because because they don't trust him
because it'll like them because it's
Thursday but even if you load or fear
Trump you must look at this and say this
can't happen in a democracy the people
voted for him you can't just
unprecedented the hell you can't
how did Margaret Thatcher wind up
becoming the ex Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom lost the election No
decided to retire now forced out by the
votes of just 356 members of the House
of Commons from her own party and she
still got the majority of those votes
and was forced out anyway
three of Britain's last five prime
ministers became prime minister without
first being elected Winston Churchill
became their wartime prime minister in
1940 did not win an election for the job
until 1951 so don't tell me this isn't
democratic not only is the the English
example pertinent but among other things
this is in our Constitution right now
and on February 23rd of next year it
will celebrate its 50th anniversary of
being in our Constitution here's hoping
we have a big birthday party that day
for it and I have just the right theme
for it and you know who burst out of the
25th amendment birthday cake right
that's right Acting President Mike Pence
Happy Thanksgiving resist peace